personalità più bisognosi nuova
challenge slime e qualche allora se tu
mi è piaciuto un sacco lasciava già tre
colori di colle la sales 5 colori di
criteri lascia le nostre colore più
circolo di glitter e non mi ricordo se
cos'altro previsite di fare un'altra
sale già pensato con cos'altro potremmo
farla con i pigmenti tra l'altro io non
ho mai usato i bastimenti nello slime so
che fanno un effetto bellissimo spaziale
metallizzato gas ma anche realizzato
quindi sono super curiose di provarli
questa parola prima volta che li proverò
in più come challenge
le regole sono semplicissime dovremmo
davvero darti pescare tre colori di
pigmenti favore sono ben darti e poi
dovremo viziarli tutti nello slime e
vediamo di che colore diventa sono
troppo curiosa e poi vincerà chi avrà lo
slime più belle per evitare evitare e io
sono malefica malefica c'è stato un
incidente mondo ordinato questi pigmenti
praticamente gli ordinati su amazon e mi
sono arrivati el atmosfera completamente
gialla ho detto oh mio dio che vuole
dire
per sbaglio fumetti sono gialli come
faccio a fare tre colori tutti i gialli
e poi l'offerta e ho scoperto che questo
qua questo giallo malefico si era
spaccato tutto e ha riempito tutti gli
altri di pigmento ecco perché sono
controlli minuti vuol dire se il bianco
giallo verde quindicenne sul tacco a
pulirli e a sistemarli tutti però non
volevo buttato questo gioco perché
l'unico dorata lo sai oro se ci capita
quindi io spero prima di iniziare dico
quale spero che mi capitino oro
attenzione di mele ce n'è solo uno
incredibile von bergen italo meglio che
la pescarolo lorca nato riteniamo di
qualcuno allora la maledizione
comunque so che mi capiti oro ed emir
questo brogi facciamo sott'acqua lo
slide detrarre maggio e poi anche questo
rosso sembra ben in rosso corallo non lo
sapranno tutti bellissimi perché sono
proprio per la t e metallizzati sono
troppo curioso di vedere come riuscirà
il nostro zaia with police per i
criticando invece tanto questo coi viola
è bello
anche questi celesti sono belli entrambi
quindi tu sei di essere però c'è poi il
sel a quelli che sarebbe come il colore
del mio team
beh io ci sono team azzurro giallo
vestiranno i colori del nostro team e io
spero solo che non mi capiti ovviamente
il verde ma anche il nero perché sono si
scurisce troviamo bianco ma andiamo da
bellissimo effetto tipo porcellato sì
quindi sicuramente mi capiterà verde
nero è nato o barometro per avvisare i
colori brutti non è il verde grigio e
marrone
ok allora consiglio di sicuro che altre
il soul the rings pare di quale colore
con che cosa bacino attrezzato di sport
estremi commenti lasciati un bel live
siamo anche appunto vederne altre e ora
iniziamo subito la carta forbici passato
[Musica]
[Applauso]
remoto offerta
già su quella mano quella manovra perché
questo non c'è beh aspetta ok dai più
avanti sono tutti in linea si vede
neanche questo di specchi ti basta mai
toccato cosa vuoi vedere che è mio è un
rosso ha parlato leggero ma lo so
individuale per l'abito rosa
ok tocca a me mi spieghi pure per ischia
sì io sono gli occhi ei miei occhi
chiusi
il silenzio pata pata mi sto divertendo
dai poi andare allora perché mi stava
spingendo qua
non mi fido allora balla trend mi attira
books questo ottimo
quella i miei capelli con tutte le
opzioni che c'erano mia vita quello che
non volevo
avevamo già chi vincerà la vediamo in
rosa di vitale devo andare piano piano
penale con la sensazione che questi ma
che bello vedi un po buona già tanto si
è sì perché si espande il tacco
corriamo invidiano
[Musica]
sto diventando ha parlato c'è già è
bello così è già bello grazie bubble
gigante abbiamo il mio ed ai tifosi
uscirà sicuramente un bel galaxy ma che
stavolta ma proprio nel breve motivi tra
pepè stai dicendo la caccia a perdere ma
che ne metto porto brava così diventa
credo sia arrivato
ovvio che strano la nostra diventando
proprio nero nome non ho però sembra
davvero ragazzo e pepe
c'è ma che differenza con il ruolo che
brutta da quando uno è bravo isla cioè
non ha neanche riflesso non lo so
brutto catherine grigio la vita a
momenti per scopo della speriamo di
essere più fortunati con poche alte ben
darti un peccato che in colore
sfortunato questa comunità vediamo io
spero che mi chiarito ancora il
bellissimo che rimanga anche sul rosa
ok
vai non c'è niente che avanti più
indietro allora la linea e così pure
nuovo ignorato quello che sposo per
abbellire rosell dorato di diventare
scorso perché mi chiami di colore
decente che possono a rubarlo a questo
punto siccome che è scuro biscari
mischia spero che mi capiti un bronzo o
viola
[Musica]
anzi io non dovevo dire l'ho già fatto
dopo però ma qua sono da loro la linea è
questa
ok questo non ci credo
battuto in posizione verticale che
quindi vuol dire che l'ultimo tour
ingredienti sarà inverno poi quel punto
di adobe air e allora è fatta che
andiamo alle serre ci fate pure i big
mentre salvezza ci tenne perché è il
bianco e nero e grigio grigio
ora vediamo pronuncia lo schermo ho
paura troppo forti o beve mezza
tantissimo è finito di pop no oddio di
questo tantissimo diventerò svolte sono
sicuro
che figata
questo stupendo ma guardate verona scout
peccato mi hanno messo troppo no meglio
e sempre più brillante
mamma mia che ormai pare che tu hai mai
fatto nei colori grigio è sì davvero
bello il mio sly colore come il colore
del mio team ovvero per me no invece la
cascata me questo servizio grigio chiaro
mi ha detto un po così
purtroppo ne sono la carità magari
diverten max mindjack vediamo dai magari
lo migliora un pochino sta diventando un
grigio e un po per lato forte ma chiesta
diventando grigio ha proprio parlato
[Musica]
no no no perché riflessi spesso che
orami capi di un colore perché è
l'ultima possibilità di salvarmi seno è
però non è male vediamo vediamo a un po
di riflessi quindi non è molto colorato
libro taxi sporco
ultimo turno mischiato a spetta perché
il capiti un core ore otto di loro
figlia si vuole così paranza menti ci
vuole un colore delicato
si tratta di un chiaro atto che il dm
questa ultima dove stop d'agosto
questa è la linea
non ci fortuna bronzo per i misti tutti
così vediamo se riesce a scegliere un
colore belli riprende colore scuro così
come il nero viola blu rosso viola blu
oro ma si sa che cosa che non si avverte
va bene o nero o bianco franchi dove
sono parte cosa sono
si ok allora mi devo lasciar guidare dal
mio istinto
[Musica]
beh credo possa andare con questo ti
posso cambiare cioè scritte città da
questi due decide no ma non questo come
qui tutto questo era meglio con l'altro
però ci riesco è un celeste è super
chiaro però almeno è un colore 270 mai
per scegliere un bianco o quell'altro
nei romani non ha precisato ha dovuto
alla legge avverte gotto dove pure qui
lo scavo del verde io volevo quanto bene
così questa all affianca più bello
questo anche questi quindi i nets e
vabbè ma se moltissimi adesso magari non
tre colori maxi brewery cosa ne pensate
pure mischiano con il super colorate di
allora come diventa il tuo che fortuna
abbiamo beccato i colori dei nostri team
prezzo di giallo viola fino proiezione
qui c'è il tappo non è mai vediamo ma
non esce come no si staccano fanno bene
questo color bronzo che tocco ma prendo
un poker tocco per omesse fighissimo e
si è il mio una sorta di gold bronzo è
troppo bello non vuoi che ti patico sei
contento molto avresti voluto prendere
altri colori avrei voluto prendere il
viola è ma poi diventava un po strano i
viola però europeo realizzato rivediamo
l'unico come diventa allora ecco poi il
celeste compreso è un po chiaro vedete
queste le lo salvi chi può brava bastano
pochi retata che bello
una strada con the ram e schermo bene
però forse sì forse diventasse
incredibile market i nostri team
esatto siamo ancora un po adesso si
rifiuta di assorbirlo sta diventando un
po grilletto metallizzato tipo io magari
a faccia time no volevo dire tu fai gold
live e io faccio l'argento off line
magari poi diventa più bello il mio
futuro è strano perché ha dei riflessi
blu ma la maggior parte sono color
argento
beh effettivamente con il bianco il nero
ha fatto gene 48 un po d argento umani
dal blu è un colore davvero bello di con
celeste metallizzato e quindi poi ti
penso di più per ora il tuo addio a voi
con la pioggia di più prima di essere
attivato il mio quello di vitale
prospetta facciamo nato non compariamo
lì e vediamo come va questa quello di
anita e questo è il mio allora il mio
più metallizzato il tuo è più gold è più
brillante è brillantissimo allora che si
fa
incredibile la coincidenza è professore
nostri colori giallo ma proprio stand o
quello stesso colore della tua maglietta
quindi ora andiamo ad attivarli poi me
li facciamo vedere potrete dargli il
voto da 1 a 10 per aspetto per sony smr
e poi nostro dato potrete votare chiavi
ecco qua il mio slime io sono veramente
contenta di come il sito
guardate che colore stupendo cioè un
celeste metallizzato bellissimo allora
voglio farvi vedere bene le sfumature
guardate un po bellissimo
non pensavo che uscisse così bello
questo prossimo con i pigmenti è
praticamente un ottima metallizzato
netta su un po che bello zeri colore
stupendo decisamente gli sla infatti per
i pigmenti escono bene
troppo bello riflessioni su quelli fissi
che ha
guardate riflessi un po argentati un po
bianchi quindi alla fine il pigmento
bianco e nero non è stato male come idea
è bellissimo da un bel bps trovo questo
colore
certo poi voglio fare solo due con i
pigmenti di no scherzo però veramente
stupendo l'effetto quindi questa è il
mio slime metallizzato celeste celeste
metallizzato il coraggio quel selezione
tali stato delle macchine e ora benino
quello digitale se alla fine il sito
meglio dei video vediamo
guardate per te l'aspetti e per il mio
che entrano diventata rialzo né alla
fine io e orange gold che è bello non so
se potete apprezzare al meglio e quasi
un pesca adorato color pesca dorato e
super allungabile super estensibile
estende ed è bellissimo giocarci e molto
tenue come colore molto delicato
morbidoso che può invece ma non troppo
molle no bolle non fa le bolle puoi
vedere bene questo colore solo qui si
vede questo è il colore quindi è un po
metallizzato ma stranamente il migliore
è rimasto più metallizzato del tuo
nonostante il suo simili nei colori
il gruppo più per lato glitterato è
salito da però bello mi piace molto
tenue fine non è diventato super volte
come
il secondo colore secondo pigmento di te
mi è capitato che marmo cioè la pena
differente li super metallizzato e
perché un click
credo che l'ultimo pigmento che hai
preso era molto metallizzato quindi con
ti piace di più tra i due
questo grido chant ho il mio celeste
metallizzato la mia società guarda
sembra valutando i programmi degli altri
mi perdoni allora votate questo dolce
servizio in salette io ho servizio di
date in più allora perche dovremmo
commenti che altri talenti se volete che
facciamo con i pigmenti magari io vi
lasciamo qua 4 vaselines quid carini i
nuovi video lady channel islands a lance
con la ruota
buona visione